(calming orchestral music)
- These days,
rose water is something of a beauty trend,
but it's been in use for centuries.
It's thought to have
originated in what is now Iran,
and it's a cultural
staple there to this day.
(calming orchestral music)
This Great Big Story
is inspired by Genesis.
(bright music)
For the world's best rose water,
you have to go to the
Qamsar district in Iran.
There, you will find Mohsen,
who comes from a long
line of rosewater makers.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Announcer] And there's
a reason Mohsen's family
has been making rose
water here for centuries.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Announcer] Those special
conditions, like the soil,
temperature, sea level, and gentle winds,
makes the Qamsar district
ideal for growing roses.
A lot of roses.
(speaking in foreign language)
(calming orchestral music)
(footsteps echoing)
(petals ruffling)
(quirky music)
(water rushing)
- [Announcer] The flowers
are boiled with water
in large copper pots, where
condensation is collected.
(speaking in foreign language)
(quirky music)
- Unfortunately,
times are changing for
the rose water industry.
There aren't as many family
farms as there once was,
but for some, like Mohsen and his family,
making rose water is
more than a a business.
(speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic orchestral music)
(bright music)